[Applause]
the image of the black Nazarene paraded
around old Manila escorted by a sea of
barefoot
Believers the procession is one of the
greatest modern spectacles of the
Catholic faith after being downsized for
the past 3 years due to concerns over
covid-19 it returns this year with the
Filipino brand of Catholicism on full
display I'm waiting for Statics but I am
here and I am alive because of the
miracle of the black Nazarene I believe
he has the answers to my
problems the centuries old statue of
Jesus Christ was in a glass case for the
first time but this did not prevent
devotees from scrambling to get on the
float they believe the closer they are
to the image the more they'll be granted
its gift of Miracle the last time the
black nazarine procession was held back
in 2020 more than 2 million people took
part now the pandemic may have held back
the annual tradition but clearly
devotees have held on to their
faith at one point the float looked like
it was going to tip over it stopped
moving for a while as devz took turns
climbing and dropping into the
thickening
crowd it feels good to be able to touch
him it feels like our aspirations are
within
reach the massive procession takes place
just one month after a bomb exploded at
a Catholic service in the south claimed
by ISO but devotes say they believe the
black Nazarene will protect them today
and in the year ahead Barn below Al
jazer
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer